hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
saint augustine is often talked about as
a christian philosopher indeed a very
important and central christian
philosopher so when we're thinking about
his work the confessions one of the
things that we do want to be attentive
to is the
interconnection and the comparisons
between philosophy or philosophies
and christianity and we do have to say a
few things right off the start
augustine at the beginning of his life
and for a long time doesn't really
understand
christianity he half understands some
things gets other things wrong
um you know mistakes the the notion of
god he's got mistaken ideas about jesus
for a while and he he tells us all about
this in various chapters of the
confessions he also you know gets to
learn philosophy along the way so it's
not as if augustine is simply
confronting us with
christianity capital c
ready made you know entirely uh put
together and philosophy as if there was
some sort of generic philosophy that
included every single thing that we call
philosophy and then you know putting
them side by side like that no it's it's
taking place in the course of a
life it's in a situated way
and you know
we can ask ourselves something really
important
what philosophy does augustine
actually
know and you know if we read uh not even
between the lines but just pay attention
to what's being said in the text of the
confessions
we'll come to see that he actually has
had a pretty good background in
philosophy you know for example we know
that cicero's hortensius is the the book
that gets him oriented towards
philosophy and towards wisdom in general
it arouses this desire within him and
he's read other of cicero's works as
well
we know this in part because when he's
when he's criticizing faustus he
actually says this guy has only read a
little bit of cicero and also a little
bit of seneca we know from augustine's
other works that he he knows the stoics
right seneca is one of the key stoics
seneca's writing in latin so is cicero
and so augustine has access to you know
these books and to their their doctrines
and thinkers so you know cicero who's an
eclectic
seneca
aristotle you know he references
aristotle's categories and he says okay
nice book what does it actually do for
helping me understand say god or
anything like that it's not particularly
helpful
and we can assume that augustine is
running across other of aristotle's
ideas not least through getting them
through seneca and cicero who reference
aristotle at various points in their
works cis was actually a huge fan of
aristotle right particularly in
augustine's own
discipline of rhetoric so so he knows
aristotle he talks at one point about
the epicureans and he says you know i
would i'd probably be attracted to being
an epicurean uh if it wasn't for the
fact that you know the epicureans think
that um we don't go anywhere after we we
die so you know that that's an important
thing he does know their doctrines he's
probably read some epicurean texts that
we don't actually have access to since
there's so little he references the
academics at a number of different
points the academics were the platonists
when the platonic academy had become a
hotbed of skepticism academic skepticism
we we talked about and augustine says
well you know they get some things right
and other things they don't
the philosophers that he probably feels
the greatest affinity with uh and he's
not unusual among christian early
christian philosophers in this are what
he calls the
platonus and he you know actually tells
us about um reading the the uh
translations
of the platonists that are that are
provided um
by this uh
this this this latin author
and that's you know
quite important is he reading plato
himself
we don't really know
you're also going to get a lot of plato
through
cicero and seneca and other writers but
he's also probably
reading platinus and other platonists as
well
through this and those are the ones that
we're probably going to draw the most
interesting comparisons
too right so
you know that's that's quite important
there um
and we also have a discussion when he's
referencing
manny the leader or the founder of
manichaeism he tells us that there are
these philosophers and this might
include
astronomers mathematicians you know it's
not as if you only did philosophy
and you didn't do any other disciplines
it might have included people with
medical knowledge and he said that there
were these these philosophers who had
accounts of the natural world that were
actually on point you know they could
predict eclipses they could make sense
out of natural phenomena and manny
wasn't able to do that so we know that
he's he's got a pretty significant
background
in philosophy we also know that
augustine is like many people in ancient
times not just reading these
philosophers but trying to live in
accordance with them he's experimentally
trying philosophies out in the course of
his life so that's quite important
now
early on again going back to the
the hortensius and also
other
parts of the book
from book three onward
philosophy is going to get compared to
other ways of attaining wisdom
philosophy is about attaining wisdom and
you know when it comes to manichaeism
augustine says philosophy turns out to
be or the philosophers turn out to be
more plausible and accurate than all
these fables and ramblings of the
manichaean literature you know augustine
actually meets with somebody who's
supposed to explain it the bishop
faustus who isn't able to explain it and
manichaeism kind of loses its its
attractiveness from that point on
early on
philosophy seems way better than the
christian scriptures
why would that be the case
well you know the christian scriptures
like augustine points out are you know
written
in ways that are
kind of murky and mysterious on the one
hand but they also appeal to be appear
to be written at a we could say lower
grade level than philosophy right
they're written for
ordinary people to be able to make sense
of and that you know lowers them in some
respect in augustine's view philosophy
is
higher up but
you know
this is going to change over time
another key aspect that sort of arguing
for philosophy for augustine you know
some philosophy does seem to get matters
right like he said you know the
epicureans you know they're on to
something they just they've got these
mistaken beliefs about life and death
and you know the after world and the
gods and so you can't really entertain
them i mean aristotle's categories
aren't completely useless even if they
can't tell us about god
um you know a lot of the things that the
uh stoics or cicero or the plaintiffs
have to say
pretty good stuff
so why then
would we want christianity why would we
be attracted to something beyond greek
philosophy
what's philosophy missing we can say or
to frame it another way
less you know negative way what does
christianity provide or offer or
reveal
that we're not going to get out of
philosophy
and here we can uh you know look at a
few
passages so
in book seven chapter nine right
we have this interesting back and forth
comparison between what scriptures tell
us
and what
pagan philosophy specifically platonism
is going to tell us as well
so uh we have a a similarity here in
that they both talk about the word the
logos right the gospel of john and lots
of different
modes of philosophy we'll we'll talk
about you know that so he says um
by means of a certain man puffed up with
most unnatural pride you procured for me
certain books of the platonus that have
been translated out of greek into latin
in them i read not indeed in these words
but very much the same thought enforced
by various arguments that and here he
quotes the gospel of john in the
beginning was the word and the word was
with god and the word was god the same
was in the beginning with god all things
were made by him and without him nothing
was made what was made in him his life
and the life was the light of men and
the light shines in the darkness and the
darkness did not comprehend it pretty
good right i read that the soul of man
though it gives testimony of the light
is not itself the light but the word god
himself is the true light
so you know overlaps there so what is
christianity contributing he goes on he
says
but that he came into his own and his
own did not receive him but as many
received him to them he gave power to be
made the sons of god that i didn't read
in these books i'm not getting that from
philosophy
again i read that the word god was born
not of the flesh nor of blood nor of the
will of man nor the will of the flesh
but of god
so that's an overlap but i did not read
there that the word was made flesh and
dwelt among us
right so there's all these things that
he's going to bring up including uh
here's some examples
that he emptied himself taking the form
of a servant being made in the likeness
of man and inhabit found his man that he
humbled himself
becoming obedient unto death even to the
death of the cross these are not in the
works of the plaintiffs as a matter of
fact if the plaintiffs hear about this
sort of thing they're going to be like
that's that's a terrible god we don't
want to worship anything like that you
know so um
there's there's there's quite a few
other things where there's there's
more
uh to christianity and more to the
christian ideas than are going to be
found in
platonism
and platonism is sort of the best
philosophy right a little bit later in
that same chapter he says you know i had
this kind of mistaken idea about
christ only being a man of surpassing
wisdom who knew no other man could equal
right but
christianity is teaching us that
in fact christ is
the son
and god incarnate so these are some
really
important points
he also says at that time after reading
these books of the platonist
and being instructed to them to search
for incorporeal truth i clearly saw
your invisible things which are
understood by the things that are made
that's a reference to
paul's writings right something that is
often viewed as a sort of argument for
the existence of god looking at the
things that are made to going to
a maker and he says although pushed
backwards by my search i perceived what
that was which because of my mind's
darkness
i was not permitted to contemplate i was
made certain you exist you're infinite
though not diffused through space either
finite or infinite that you're truly
he who is always the same and he goes on
and on he says of these truths i was
most certain but i was too weak to find
my
joy
in you and so this is going to come
through studying
scripture
the scriptures as he's going to tell us
later
they
they have a
deeper and richer meaning
when they're interpreted properly
interpreted perhaps in an allegorical
manner or a spiritual matter not just as
what they're literally
saying so this is uh something very
important for augustine he recognizes
that philosophers reading the literal
level might say well this this is not
helpful at all this is just kind of you
know silly mumbo jumbo but um with a
proper hermeneutic scripture can tell us
a lot
this provides us then with a much fuller
understanding of god of human beings of
jesus christ the son of our spiritual
destiny you might say
and allows a better grasp on how human
beings ought to live again philosophy
certainly has all sorts of useful things
to say about the value of friendship and
the need for virtue
christianity
particularly through the scriptures but
also through christian practice and the
engagement of the human being with god
is going to
provide an enhanced a
more purified a further conception of
how one ought to live and a great
example of this is provided in the
discussion of the
importance of the life of saint anthony
and how that could draw people to
monasticism
monasticism is something that greek
philosophy did not produce but which
christianity did and it's not something
radically antithetical to a
philosophical way of life in fact later
on past augustine's time monasticism is
going to be called the christian
philosophy in the early middle ages and
so there's a lot going on here in this
interplay between philosophy and
christianity augustine is not
just throwing philosophy away or saying
that it's a ladder that you ascend and
then get rid of
he's trying to integrate philosophy and
christianity into something where
christianity is providing the ultimate
framework but philosophy
does
have some place some role to play not
for everybody but certainly for a person
like augustine himself
you